les présidentielles la campagne
électorale se poursuit à meeting était
très attendu c'était celui que devait
présider hier soir à
montigny-lès-cormeilles monsieur georges
marchais 12000 personnes assistaient à
ce meeting affirme l'humanité de ce
matin notre confrère le matin lui parle
de 3000 participants mais finalement le
nombre importe peu ce que les
observateurs ont surtout retenu c'est le
soutien à sans faille apporté par
monsieur georges marchais au maire de
montigny les cormeilles dans sa campagne
contre le trafic de la drogue
nous posons des problèmes de
l'immigration
ce serait pour utiliser et favoriser le
racisme nous recherchions à flatter et
plus bas à stains nous menons la lutte
contre la drogue
ce serait parce que nous ne voulons pas
combattre l'alcoolisme apprécié et
répandu dans notre clientèle pour la
jeunesse je choisis moi oui je choisis
les tue le sport la lune et non à 30
alors comme l'autre jour un dirigeant
socialiste
ils crient tous en choeur pénis quelle
honte
quelle honte quelle idée la vente à ce
fonds ces gens là des travailleurs borne
est un dû arsys ali colis bruton voilà
d'après noté tracteur qui vont de la
droite au parti socialiste
comment seraient les ouvriers et les
ouvrières de telles attaques ne
déshonore que leurs auteurs et ne
méritent que le mépris